what are your feelings on the caravan
situation what do you guys think about
that from all the people that are
getting in here every day like what is
it but it's a fault it's a fake thing
we're supposed to be paying what exactly
happen with the caravan so they're
making a big publicity event out of
these people that want to come to
America well they want to sell them
so ms-13 and the gang are the biggest
employers there you don't join them you
get your family nice guys and I think
that these people are desperate they're
essentially refugees from a place that's
intolerable but they're making it this
really big political deal yeah it's very
publicized totally and apparently
they're always walking like sometimes
they get in the vans and people drive in
place I don't know what you'd say that
we shouldn't let him in or we should
with other men this is what I'm saying
let me say that's the issue well yeah we
definitely don't people don't want a
minute they're illegal immigrants but
what's interesting to me is like if you
come from Cuba you can just come yeah if
you get on a boat you get over here in
America but like you made it bro come on
in yeah have you tried from Guatemala
like nah sorry son wrong patch of dirt
find another made an agreement that
anybody who's trying to escape the kind
of shitty situation they have in Cuba
will allow that right oh I got to
Colombia I mean if you if your Yoel
Romero and you come over from Cuba yes
you look like that's true you cuz your
comment will take you people think that
like all Mexicans are like for the
caravan and too you know we want them
you know that's not sure now most
Mexicans are another country yeah you
know to me Mexicans ain't down for it
for that Caravan they want them turned
away too
it's a complicated emotional issue man
it's like I always do this joke where I
believe in borders but I'd be a shitty
border control agent right like I do
think borders are reasonable by nobody
gets over and then I'd be like the kids
[ __ ] it come on I think Americans feel
that way at that you know it's a it's a
hard do you live in a gated community
no okay I mean yes all right no it is a
it's like the idea that there's
real country that there's a place where
you can go in a place where you can go
and like you have to have papers and
they across this line the dirt like
they've set up fences and borders well
the reason that exists right I mean if
you think about the United States right
the United States essentially is not
just a country it's a collection of
different areas right in each different
area has its own culture their own
almost their own language you know the
way they talk and Florida is way [ __ ]
different than way they talk in Maine
it's really weird it's all the same
language but it's almost like there's
separate little countries and we travel
amongst each other no problem and you're
allowed to you'll have to bail out I'm
gonna try to Vegas for a while I'm gonna
get me a job at a casino
nobody cares like you're fine as long as
you're honest one patch of dirt but the
reason why we don't allow all the other
patches of dirt to do the same thing and
everybody just flow freely is because
there's some spots that just don't have
it good at all and we want those people
to stay there although you haven't
thought your spot you haven't fixed you
know what the connector next your spot
but you know what the connective tissue
is for Americans besides they even
though that's true the connective tissue
that I think a lot of countries don't
have is that the one thing we have gone
for even if it's even if it's a myth for
a lot of people freedom the one thing
all Americans have gone form is is no is
the idea that there's a chance if I do
the right thing
I may be poor now all American but I
could be a [ __ ] millionaire [ __ ] is
so and but that's what keeps the sort of
that's what has nothing from running
from creating a revolution yeah but if
we lose that you can let everybody in
from Kentucky if everybody from Kentucky
decide to move to LA we would just have
to deal with it that's American they got
citizenship that's what I'm saying yeah
like it's not the reason why we can't
have world cities it's the object of
some places suck too hard you don't want
nationalism I'm not saying that it's
good or bad I'm just looking at it as a
thing right now if I had to say do I
like it
honestly I think the whole world as the
human beings as a race would be way
better off if everybody could move where
it's good and then we would figure out
why there's too many people
good and then they'll settle down and
you move to a better spot and then
eventually even out yeah you know the
reason why I ever happened but we never
even the reason why in segregated areas
don't advance like these people in
Sentinel island so kind of a [ __ ] up
example Satan's Island they're saying
going anywhere like this is they're
wearing leaves over their dead right but
they like them but for six do they but
but do Joe European humans would by the
way you and I don't war on okay if we
were living on that island we would be
having leaves over our dick too yeah
it's not like oh I'm just a satellite
these [ __ ] morons Christ like we
don't know how to do any that stuff so
we would be with them just with a
greater understanding of what's possible
you just say Bohr around know what you
just said is happening in the European
Union I mean that's why a lot of Polish
people come under the you can and they
come back and you know well there's and
there's also what they're doing now with
immigration is freaking a lot of people
out because they're allowing so many
people of different cultures to come in
and then their cities become more
multicultural than they are English and
then it gets real weird but the other
problem is that when you have currency
currencies used to be based on the
productivity of their citizenry right
mm-hm so when you have currency
everybody has the same currency which
means it's all value the same thing
problem is that people in Spain are not
as productive as people in Germany for
example so the German goods and services
should be worth more or the dollar there
that the euro there should be worth more
than it is say in you know space isn't
it better when the state has more power
than the Fed well that's like country's
better
that's basically what because the
argument is is we're like a band of
countries a country no when isn't it
better for the people so then that would
mean you know at the same rate you know
it's better to have a country like the
United States than to be right
socialized with States you can go to any
state yeah
with country yeah you can try getting in
Japan I mean Japan I mean yeah you can't
get in there I think or something would
you say Japanese took like 10 Syrians
tried getting into Canada
than these days ever they're very
liberal in Canada beasts to live in
because these the celebrities like I'm
so sick yeah but ways I'm headed to
Canada if you have a DUI law that you
went it's true it's a piece